foreign
we're gonna wait a minute here for
everybody to come over from the demo
thank you so much for joining us
hi everyone
how's everyone's day going
let's see if it pushed everybody over
here
hey Ryan
hello much for the great demo
my pleasure
okay let's see if it's gonna push
everybody over here I just re-shared the
Q a link in the chat as well
give everybody
let's say two minutes here
hey Sanjay hey Sergey
thank you
nice to see you all in in the YouTube
chat here
okay I can see a good number of us are
coming over here so I think we can we
can get started but hi everybody so nice
to see you here on YouTube hope
everyone's having a great Wednesday and
thanks for joining us over here for the
live q a
and thank you so much Ryan for the great
pins demo as well
um I guess we could all introduce
ourselves here too if I haven't met
anybody yet I'm Rachel Dempsey I lead
our customer marketing and pro Community
here at posit uh and Ryan and I are
joined by a special guest here today
Isabel if you want to introduce yourself
hi everyone I am Isabel I am the
maintainer of the pins for python
package and also the Jennifer for python
package
um which is a model Ops package that
lives very closely to pins um so it's
got a lot of love for this Nifty little
tool that I get to use all the time that
is quite useful for my for my everyday
work
thanks for having me that's awesome
thank you again for joining us Isabelle
and Ryan I know you introduced yourself
before in the demo but why don't you
introduce yourself again here too yeah
absolutely yeah so Mom I'm Ryan I'm a
data science advisor here at posit and
I'm the one whose voice you just heard
for the last half hour I really don't
enjoy giving these demos uh and I hope
you all are finding them valuable and
it's pretty hard to believe I've already
been doing this for five months
um but hopefully this structure works
well for you I saw a lot of great
feedback afterwards in the chat and so
we're certainly going to incorporate
that feedback into future demos everyone
love any additional feedback and love
all of your questions about pins
workflows pause the team all that fun
stuff
awesome well I was talking to a few
different Community Builders and we were
talking about fun questions to ask
people in the community and I would love
to ask you all here what's something
that you're proud of this month and
maybe Ryan and Isabelle you could answer
that for me too
is Bill you want to go first
I put you all I put everybody on the
spot here but I love hearing these
answers
I think in a non-data science world I'm
so proud of I have a five-month-old
puppy that is
um a little high energy and she finally
learned how to sit and down this month
um which is very exciting uh maybe in a
data science world I have been a long
time contributor uh and user of pins but
it was just within the last month that I
was promoted to maintainer so that is
also something I'm very proud of and
excited to continue working with
congratulations that's awesome
Ryan what about you
um I would say from like a non-data
sciency non-posit thing
um my wife and I are expecting our first
kid in December and we've procrastinated
a lot and preparing for this kid and I
finally painted the baby room and I am
very proud of that
congratulations
okay I'll go non-data science
um I've been taking learning guitar more
seriously the past few months and I've
actually been practicing a lot more uh
work related
we're working on releasing a new posit
connect page that I've worked on a lot
the first iteration of it and hopefully
that's going to be going Live this week
so really excited about that
okay I don't know if anybody was writing
in the chat but they're proud of too but
would love to would love to hear that
because I really enjoyed it said like
Yay puppies yay babies yeah
awesome well let's jump into some of the
questions from earlier
um as a reminder you can ask questions
anonymously too but you can also use the
YouTube chat here so on the screen it
says the short link POS dot i t slash
demo Dash questions that will bring you
to slido where you can ask anonymously
um and we'll be hanging out here for 15
20 however many minutes you all are
asking questions
um but one of the questions from earlier
was
are pins mainly for sharing data between
users or can R code be shared or pinned
as well
yeah I can probably take that one and
Isabel you can add any additional
comments
um pins are really great for sharing
typically objects so things like data
sets models plots no objects in R and
python in terms of code itself we would
certainly suggest some type of Version
Control using git for example publishing
your source code to GitHub which makes
it super easy to share that source code
with other users so I wouldn't
necessarily say pins is a great way for
sharing code but it is a fantastic way
for sharing uh the objects that you're
creating in arm python
thank you I would completely agree with
that if you're looking to use the best
tool for the job I would say a Version
Control for code and then pins for a
little slice of data or not necessarily
large data sets this is not a
replacement for a database
but being able to share code quickly
with others probably not for pins
so Isabelle I know you helped me answer
this question in slido but the question
was why do you paste the API key in the
Jupiter notebook is that a security risk
so this is a demo um this is not a
security risk for us in this very moment
um it is best practice to be using a
package called dot ends uh in the python
world in the r World it will
automatically load from your environment
when you make the board connect but in
Python if you use that dot ends package
you can use a DOT EnV file and it will
load in all of your environment
variables then you don't have anything
in plain text and you can share your
screen with others and they won't see
your API keys
and is dot m it's just like b-o-t-e-n-v
yep
um kind of like the phonetic spelling of
like the period EnV file okay
thank you
okay another question I'll copy over to
show on the screen here
is wondering about
the speed with large data sets or
objects and the relative merits of
different uh object load methods local
directly from pins loaded into memory
from pin can either of you speak to that
um I can at least start in something
it's a bell already briefly mentioned
that um pins is really great for sharing
these like final products that you've
built whether that be like a cleaned up
data set or a polished model or just
really pretty plot that you want to
share with other people or other pieces
of content for example it is not a
substitute for storing terabytes of data
for example
um and we should you should really
consider using a database for stuff like
that so I I always personally like you
know if I have a raw data set I clean it
up it's nice and pretty and I want that
data set to feed into a lot of different
pieces of content that's a perfect use
case for pins in my opinion there's
about anything else you want to add
there
no I think that was great
um there is a suggested limit on
um the pins documentation of 500
megabytes
um that is what we've tested up to and
we know pins is super equipped to handle
so anything after that is a little bit
at your own risk
um for the speed and I guess the merits
of loading from different places
foreign
thank you I'm going to jump over to some
of the YouTube questions here and I see
Rebecca hi Rebecca asked um are there
other feet so pins is newish are there
other features in the pipeline I see the
delete old versions mentioned I don't
mean anything is lacking just curious
so for between the two packages
um there's a little bit of work right
now of getting pins python which is even
newer than pins are up to speed uh
specifically looking at versions and
non-version Boards looking at being able
to depart Sports so move these into
different files for like pipelining
things with data burn specific
um I don't know if there's really
anything big on the horizon but we're
always looking for Community input
especially when people are looking for
new locations of boards
um there are other locations Beyond
posit connect like AWS or Google Cloud
GitHub was one kaggle was one as well as
like local folders as well
um just a follow-up there so is it
500 megabytes per pin object or 500
total in pin
per pin object
okay cool thank you
uh let's see Harlan ICA you had a
question here can the data stay on the
data server without having to be
transferred to the pin server this is
just to keep data security model
consistent without having to have two
data servers
hmm
okay so if I understand this question
there's you really think about two
different servers here data server which
maybe has like a database on it and then
the pin server in this example would
likely be posit connect
um
it's really going to be up to your use
case a lot of folks you know take their
data from a database they pull it in
they clean it up and they can reload it
to that same database and that's totally
fine I might be a work well for your
team
um but if there's a if you have posit
connect and you have these polished data
sets and you want to share that content
with other pieces of content on the
connect server you know I think it makes
a lot of sense to publish it to deposit
connect so that pain can be easily made
available
um but
I don't think there's really any right
answer to that specific questions kind
of based on your team's need
um anything else you want to add Isabel
no I think that that was a good answer
um and it might be helpful I know I
answered another question with this but
we're also happy to chat directly with
you like one-on-one so we can talk about
your specific use use case and I put a
link in there in just a few
messages ago in the chat so feel free to
to use that even if you're just curious
of other people across your company are
using connect as well
um I see Joseph you asked a question
that says is there any way to schedule a
workflow to run based on an event for
example every time a new data set is
downloaded to a directory
yeah so for The Connect server at the at
the moment it's really based on timed
scheduling um so you set a time and then
you can set it to every day every second
um it could be as infrequent as every
year two years if you had a workflow for
that which would be kind of odd
um but how you most folks kind of get
around that is they can have it you know
check for updates every minute and if
yes kind of program these if statements
if you ask if you can do something if
not it cannot do something but I
currently within posit connect at least
there's no trigger uh to set off a
workflow other than just kind of a
scheduled report
thank you I see there's a few questions
on sending emails and so maybe we'll try
and group some of these together but one
was is there a way to send an email with
the content in the body of the email
rather than as an HTML attachment
yeah I can speak to this one so the
answer is yes so when we went through
today's demo
when I created I created a quarter
document and I placed that on connect I
set that to run and as you might have
seen when you send that email it's
typically going to be a direct link to
that content on the connect server
however with our markdown there's
another package called blastula and some
of you may have heard of this package
before but what that actually allows you
to do is to embed plots tables text
directly in that email rather than a
direct link so the answer is yes you can
embed content from our markdown document
using the blastiole package and I'll
actually I'll find a link here because
we have some documentation on you doing
this
um so but yeah the answer is yes it
sounds like that could be a fun
end-to-end workflow example like really
customized emails
yeah yeah I think that would be really
cool
um yeah I'll see about that I'll say we
have some other fun stuff in the works
but I won't say anything else right now
um I see George asked the question over
on slido and said pins is awesome if I
used it I would probably have a hundred
plus pins how would all of these be
managed searched or categorized
I'm just probably there's a few
different ways you can do this
especially with using connect so connect
has some built-in organization tools
including the ability to add labels to
various pieces of content including pins
so for example if you had maybe of those
100 plus pins maybe you had five or ten
of them associated with a specific
project you can easily give those a
label and search for them easily within
the connect instance
there's also other tools some of you may
have heard of a tool called connect
widgets which allows you to take various
pieces of content doesn't have to be a
pin it can be a pin a shiny app a quarto
or markdown and essentially create like
a single document that organizes all
that content
so you'd certainly have options for
organizing your content on the connect
instance and I would definitely suggest
uh using the various labels and also
connect widgets
awesome I just shared the connect
widgets Link in the chat too
I know there's a great demo that our
Solutions Engineers have put up
um collecting pins I might run and find
this link for everyone because it is
beautiful and they have it for both R
and python
is that with the Bike Share demo
it sure is cool
um let me jump back over to YouTube oh
and Marcos asked what was that email
package called again blastula
um Rachel I just sent you a link if you
don't mind just posting that
on slack oh yep we have so many ways of
communicating with each other right now
I'm like where am I
okay
awesome yeah just put that there okay
another question over
from YouTube
can you use
the usual pin read in a shiny app or
does it have to be pin reactive read
do you want to take that Isabelle
yeah
yeah okay I'm not a huge shiny user but
I believe the way this works is pin read
is if you want to read it once and then
pin reactive read is if you want it to
update every single time some reactive
component changes
that's a perfect answer exactly what I
was gonna say
um Arthur icy asked in YouTube any plans
to offer pins for other languages
not currently
um but if someone's interested in
starting their own pins for another
language we would certainly love to
support you in your journey
I saw Libby mentioned in the chat
learning about blastula from Matthias in
a data science hangout episode where he
talked about integrating with slack and
I will definitely share that one
in the chat here as well that was a
great great call out Libby
uh let's see going over to oh well
here's the easy question for me is this
q a recorded so we can re-listen to it
yes it is uh so the recording will be
made available immediately at the same
link here
uh follow-up question on the
emails could you just create the email
on workbench and have that run from
connect when the data is updated for The
Connect pin
yeah could you just create the email on
workbench and had that run from connect
with it did yeah so actually the link
that Rachel posted a bit earlier
um it's on our solutions.posite DOT Co
website where we talk about leveraging
blastula and creating emails the way
that article actually works
um it creates like a conditional email
so it only sends an email if for example
the data is updated and then it'll send
an email if it's not it won't send an
email so I think um you might be able to
find some value checking out that
article there but you can certainly code
up these solutions to meet your needs
however you want
awesome thank you
um Marco said I need something like
blastula but for python Isabel any ideas
that's a great comment I will take that
to heart
um we're always looking for fun new
packages that exist and are especially
um because the python world has so many
great tools uh but sometimes it's those
little things that are so useful that I
think R has invested a lot of time in
tiny little packages for everyday things
another question
in slido is what are the drawbacks of
using pins to store data for example
would it be hard to find the docs if you
have many
hmm
I I mean
pins is pretty awesome I don't see a lot
of drawbacks
um
now certainly you don't want to just
take every single data set that your
team has ever created uh and you know
use and just pin it uh kind of all
willy-nilly there should be some kind of
strategy for taking this finished object
whether it be data or a model uh and
serving as a pin for a specific purpose
I think that's kind of what you want to
sit down with your team as you're
considering these pins and what you
should do with them
um but not too many drawbacks that I can
think of
um it is your favorite package I think
right it's definitely up there it's a
top three for sure
I think it could be hard to find
um
uh you know certain pieces if you have
you know one data set that you've pinned
a thousand times
um it would be difficult to parse
through each of those individually uh
there is a little like pin secret is you
can add custom metadata so maybe if you
have a lot of data that you're scared
you're not going to be able to find it
again you could add some custom metadata
fields that you could search later and
that might help with the
um large iteration over a certain data
set
and there are documentation on both of
the website on how to add custom
metadata and read it back in it's like
really idiomatically yeah that's a
really good point yeah if you have those
links you can share with me it's always
fun to be able to share pin secrets
[Laughter]
um I I'm trying to remember if I had
asked this question so apologies if it's
duplicate how would one go about sharing
a board in a project that has multiple
collaborators that all need the same
data how does a project know about the
board
sharing a board so um okay so is this
multiple people working on a single
project
um yeah well the way I interpret it is
if multiple people are working on maybe
different types of content like a shiny
app that would need a PIN or maybe a
different python visualization
or
quarter doc like how does how does that
project know that this board exists with
the PIN
hmm
so every time you're creating a new
document or a new artifact or what I
think is what is being referred to as a
project in this question you're going to
have one
one line of code two if you want to
return it across multiple lines that
says like board equals board connect or
board equals forward
folder and that is how that
specific piece of code knows about the
board and you will run that every single
time
um you create a new artifact
let me know if that does not answer your
question though and I'm happy to
elaborate more
then I think Isabel mentioned like we
talked about pinning to posit connect
that is one type of board there are
plenty of other boards you can choose
from based on how your team operates so
again for these types of demos we're
really just trying to highlight the
advantages of using posit connect as
your board
I was copying over into the chat what
Isabelle mentioned on custom metadata we
just shared the link there too
um another question from YouTube was so
if you're on a team and you do the work
in posit workbench how do you pin the
output for your team instead of it just
being used by yourself
yeah I think working workbench how do
you pin the output for your team instead
of yourselves yeah so that's a actually
kind of like a perfect use case for
positive connect
so connect you know the take home
message is that it takes anything you
publish to it a pin a shiny app quarter
document anything it makes it easily but
also kind of you can totally customize
who has access to access to it and who
you can share it with
so we talked about it I'm actually sure
if we covered it in a lot of detail in
today's demo but once it's hosted on
connect there are sharing settings and
so if you want to take that pinned
output and you want to share it with
your teammate other people that have
access to positive connect you can be
very explicit and kind of call them out
individually you can open it up to
everyone who has access to connect
server or you can open it up to the
world as well you have a lot of options
for how you can share this pinned object
with your colleagues
great thank you
uh let's see
oh what is the I think we touched upon
this just a little bit but what is the
PIN archival process
go for it as well
all right I'll send you this one
you start yeah and then I'll finish yeah
yeah so I and I guess maybe I just to
make sure I totally understand the
question and I think it's referring to
probably more like the pin versioning
um and so as you take a pin and that
data you know will essentially change
most data does you can pin it to the
same location and it doesn't overwrite
the original data it just creates
another version on top of it and so you
can essentially have multiple archived
versions of the same pin in one location
rather than having like 20 000 data sets
and I know um as we've been teasing this
demo uh on like LinkedIn and stuff we
talked about you know how to take a data
set or anything and make it like the
final version like what do you call it
is it data Final data Final one data
Final two data Final I'm totally
serious.csv
this the versioning allows you to just
have it in one location and the most
recent version will always be up to date
but you can always go back to previous
versions as well and you can kind of set
thresholds like how many you want to
save and is I'm not sure if there's like
um there are ways to trim uh certain
versions as well is that correct
that is correct you can use something
called pin
prune I believe is the the function that
you would be looking for to remove pins
at a certain interval
yeah
I loved seeing everybody's responses
when I posted about that like data Final
data final final and someone said their
favorite one was
presentation V7 final don't use this one
um Rebecca I think I maybe missed this
question earlier but you said I see the
500 megabyte in the documentation is
there a way or maybe it exists to throw
a warning if you're trying to pin
something larger than that
oh I don't know if top off the top of my
head if it does throw a warning or not
um connect will fail if you pin
something larger uh or like so large
that it can't be handled
um I don't know if we would ever have
like a hard error
um just because that is a little bit of
a fuzzy like if you pin something that's
501 megabytes I don't want your entire
pin to fail
um but this is great feedback that maybe
it should be either
something subtle uh or maybe a few more
times in documentation or somewhere uh
because yes it is hard to remember all
those nitty-gritty pieces as you're
trying to just complete an end-to-end
workflow
yeah it's good feedback thank you
um I see someone had asked in slido
could you provide an email
address for follow-up question so
I don't think I'll regret sharing this
here but you can email me directly uh so
it's just Rachel at posit.com and I'm
gonna put that in the slido as well and
I'm happy to connect you with
the right person on the team or help
make sure we we answer your questions
too I guess I could copy that over here
into it YouTube as well
and if you have specific questions on
the open source side feel free to open
an issue it doesn't have to be like a
bug or a feature request it can also be
like hey I've been thinking about pins
in this way does this use case make
sense or something like that we love
questions like that and we'd be happy to
get back to you
that's great thank you as well
another question is about and we didn't
mention conference yet the the posit
conference is coming up in just a few
weeks here and would love to see many of
you there but one of the questions was
Will some of this be included in the
posit conference in Chicago if so which
sessions
hmm
I I the only thing I can say
um we do have a kind of like a
professional tool Lounge
um where we can just hang out you don't
have to be a customer reposit you can
also just if you're a you know you love
posit and you love data science a lot of
positive employees are just hanging out
and we love talking about this stuff but
I actually will be there and I think at
least twice um we will be hosting some
demos as well some live demos and Rachel
and I were actually just talking about
this yesterday and we think like
incorporating pins into one of these
demos since obviously as you all can see
there's a lot of interest in this
package and there's various workloads
that it enables so that's the only thing
I can speak of I'm sure there's sessions
and talks that are gonna talk about pins
I don't know if Isabelle if you know any
off top of your head
I do not I know there's a few great
workshops
um that included
um
I'm sure it's in there somewhere I just
I'm not sure which one I just put the
link to the the talks and workshops so
you can search there and I think you
should just be able to search on pins as
well and see which ones
um but I will suck in what Brian said
I'm really excited for the lounge that
will be where I'm hanging out at the
posit conference to uh I guess I'll say
it here in case anybody's going to be
there it's going to be right next to the
key main keynote room so you won't miss
us there but there'll be a demo screen
so I had just slacked Ryan earlier and
said hey can we do one of these pins
demos there in the lounge too
um let me just say if there's a question
you've asked in YouTube and I've missed
it from earlier feel free to just copy
and paste it in again or bring it to the
top here
so I'm sorry if I if I've missed any
and I'm gonna go jump over to slido real
quick and see
oh this was one
I missed
um
can somebody download a pin data set or
plot directly from the board they said I
can see this being useful for a not so
technical supervisor
with posit connect you absolutely can
there's when you click on the the pinned
object there will be a link to directly
download the the pinned object
um I'm not sure for other boards but I
know you can at least do effort connect
I'm not sure for other boards
um
but my public connectives it's placed so
nicely with pins it's beautiful
I see another question from Christopher
which is if I create a board locally
with the intention to share with other
users does the board need to be created
in a shared drive or can other users
connect to a board in my file system
my understanding is that that if you do
intend to share that with others it
would have to be on a shared Drive
um but you can use things like
Dropbox and S3 buckets for more
collaborative boards including posit
connect or you can share to a local file
either on your personal computer or if
that file is on a shared network you can
share it that way
I just realized we were over the top of
the hour and didn't even notice how
clear that went by but I I think we have
gotten to most of the questions but
again if there's anything that we missed
feel free to reach out to me directly
here
um we can also continue using the the
slido link so if you wanted to just keep
asking questions here but for some
people who had like one-off questions
where you wanted to talk to us
specifically about your use case or your
team's environment
um I did make this little short link
where you could schedule a call
with us too and chat one-on-one let me
let me put this in the
cat here
is
but thank you Ryan and Isabelle here for
answering all these questions and
joining us today thank you Ryan for the
great demo as well
and thank you all for joining hopefully
I'll get to see some of you in person at
the posit conference too or even
virtually the conference is available
virtually as well
thanks everybody
thanks all right bye everybody have a
great rest of the day